welcome to the very first swipe of 2018
here's how we're kicking off the New
Year for you
angela delivers a tech punch to your
fitness goals I meet the man behind what
could be the UK's first passenger drone
and Lucy brings us a new year preview of
the big games to look forward to
all [ __ ] to come in the next ten
minutes or so after a quick look back at
some of the tech news headline says you
joined us last
Spotify has been hit with a 1.2 billion
pound copyright lawsuit for allegedly
using thousands of songs without a
license the streaming companies being
sued by Wix and music publishing that
holds the right to songs by major
artists like Neil Young the doors and
Tom Petty criminal gangs are overtaking
some vehicle security jackets being
discovered there's been a 30% increase
in car thefts over the last three years
in England and Wales according to police
data many cars are now keyless and as a
risk the signal could be captured an app
designed by a Great Ormond Street
Hospital nurse has reportedly saved
thousands of nursing hours the system
replaces the traditional clipboard at
the end of patients beds and alert staff
if they deteriorate the claim by online
dating service er minee that it had a
scientifically proven matching system
has been banned the advertising
watchdogs ruled an advert for the
website was misleading because it failed
to prove it offered people a greater
chance of finding lasting love the
company says it respectfully disagrees
and a start-up in Hong Kong that makes
human-like robots is envisioning a
future in which genius machines can earn
our trust and help solve challenges like
caring for the elderly or providing
customer services Hanson robotics
flagship bot Sofia was partly modelled
on Audrey Hepburn here's her view on
what the future holds artificial
intelligence is due to be a big theme at
the annual Consumer Electronics Show in
Las Vegas next week and of course we'll
bring you the best bits from the event
now every new year brings new year's
resolutions and for many people getting
fit is always high on the agenda
that's why angela has been looking at
some high-tech ways to help you along
with trainer Marvin Ambrosius to get his
expert take
this might look like your average
training session it's anything but this
workout simulates the testing conditions
you'd experience at an altitude of more
than two and a half thousand meters it's
designed to improve oxygen efficiency
increase endurance speed and improve
recovery by reducing the level of oxygen
it's essentially simulating a higher
altitude and the way that it works we
take air from the outside world to miss
london london air it goes through a
process called moleculus molecular
sipping all of the air goes through some
filters and then it's forced through
into the room at around about ten
percent oxygen so 10 percent of the
oxygen leaves ten percent comes in here
to essentially takes the room oxygen to
fifteen percent to your simulates around
2700 meters pop that on breathe normally
if you don't fancy that there's pod
which stands for priya climatization
on-demand a more passive way of training
in a simulated environment at a higher
altitude it also helps increase
performance by enhancing the body's
oxygen carrying capacity Mountaineers
also turn to it to help them acclimatize
on to something called prama this
concept hopes to put the fun into high
intensity interval training with
interactive technology the circuit class
is powered by pave gym flooring which is
interactive and has flashing lights to
tell participants their next move
sensors connected tracking heartrate and
timing your sprints
the Spanish concept made its debut in
London this summer but more clubs are
starting to integrate it is your my zone
belts so they're gonna monitor your
heart rate through the class
our next high-tech fitness session has
each participant wearing a tracker
called my zone to assess output you're
in the class the results are shown on a
screen to show the group who is working
hardest basically on your results screen
it will show you how long you spent in
each zone then give you your overall
effort and then the calories burn as
well so how did the classes we tried
fair with our own expert marvin ambrose
ears being able to see in utilize
technology around you to work out that's
exactly where you want to do you want to
have something that's measurable
something that you can see as successes
in something that you can use to
actually have fun and have that
unconscious fun and that's what i
noticed more than anything was that I
was having fun I wasn't really thinking
of the exercise being able to interact
and touch the laws move across the floor
with no inter we're supposed to go
technology putting new twists on
existing sports might not be for
everyone
but it won't stop the health and fitness
industry continuing to come up with new
ways to attract the tech-savvy
generations Angela Burns Sky News here's
something else to get you moving in a
very different way though the unmanned
passenger drone market might be one to
watch over the coming months I'm not
saying this is gonna be the year that I
start flying to work but the race to get
autonomous passenger vehicles in the sky
is getting exciting especially now that
a British entrepreneur has joined that
race
we already knew the future was
driverless so it makes sense that it
could be pilotless too there are several
companies around the world right now
building vehicles that could fly us
around town
sorry based entrepreneur Martin Warner
heads up one of those companies we're
testing right now we're constructing the
concept we're doing flight tests for it
we're a long way into the first where
are you doing the test very close to
here in sorry yes but you won't reveal
any more no okay I'm sorry but it's very
we're on the Kent sorry Boulder okay
people of Kenton sorry here's what you
want to be looking out for the y6s what
could become the UK's first passenger
drone giving our busiest sissies a
transport upgrade well its crowding
problems there's obstacles there's too
much traffic there's this incredible
opportunity where the technology is 30
plus years old and there's now an
opportunity to create a whole different
kind of aircraft using the same kind of
technology existing drones and have
commonalities with other forms of
aircraft if that's tackled right we
could see one day a competitor two cars
Martin believes autonomous drones will
be the next gold rush in transportation
not just something for the super-rich
the technology in the strict definition
electric vertical takeoff landing
aircraft is actually quite simple the
production of these once they're tested
and produced is actually quite cheap so
I think the ability to put a what we
call a y6 s a two-seater aircraft in the
air for someone to purchase is probably
gonna be more like a median price of
around twenty five thousand dollars and
with twenty thousand pounds the
lithium-ion battery powered why success
is designed to cover a distance of say
Heathrow Airport to Charing Cross train
station in 12 minutes a journey that
could take around an hour by car in the
short term one would hope that it would
complement any infrastructure that's
there whether it be to cross rail in
London additional types of services like
uber coming around we're gonna need more
and more and more but one day absolutely
there's going to be an air shuttle
system and people using you know
autonomous passenger drones or indeed
piloted drones as another form of
getting to work now what about safety
that must be a worry how do you get
beyond those challenges first of all
that how do we as a company satisfy
ourselves that we can make something
safe that essentially is a new category
of air vehicle and then how do we
satisfy regulators and ultimately by
doing the to you satisfy consumers the
why success lies with six rotors and six
motors if three were to foul it will
still land safely there are multiple
what we call flight redundancies which
is multiple uses of technology to ensure
that if there is a single point of
failure the aircraft will either land or
fly it where you need to be all right
what about cyber attacks
how will the drain be able to cope with
that with someone hacking in and taking
over control of the passenger drone with
technology you have to be open to the
idea of looking at new security measures
new encryption if we were worried about
this there wouldn't be facebook right
there wouldn't be the internet right
there wouldn't be an open era of
information there's always gonna be
challenges with with software what I can
tell you is that these are serialized
they're tracked we're not flying over
oceans
they're flying short distances you know
you have to assume that you are one step
ahead in terms of recursion and
constantly reviewing that and that is
for every single industry it's just
something we live with Martin believes
will see passenger drones in a skies
within as little as five years so long
as regulatory requirements can be met
we know Oh burrs deal with NASA to work
on its flying taxi project could see
testing begin in 2020
while martin plans to be on board the
first passenger flight test of his drone
later this year
video games time now an hour reviewer
lucy has been looking into the future
for us here she is with her pick of the
big games to come in 2018 Red Dead
Redemption came out in 2010 and we have
been eagerly anticipating and just
waiting for a sequel ever since and yes
2018 is that year we're getting red dead
redemption to so it's actually a prequel
of sorts in the first Red Dead
Redemption you're playing as John
Marston you know you were an outlaw in
this gang in the Wild West but you were
reformed you had a family we wanted to
leave that life behind you I am honestly
so excited to play right at redemption
to the original game is one of my
absolute favorites it's made by rockstar
games who you'll know as the people who
are behind Grand Theft Auto so they have
a lot of pedigree and it's honestly
going to be one of the biggest games of
the year
thena Mars is quite an unusual premise
and prospect for a game because it mixes
two massive brands together so you've
got all the characters in Final Fantasy
and you have all of these Disney
characters meeting up and going on
adventures together
what the Kingdom Hearts games do really
well is let you travel to these worlds
that you know so well from like the
films that you watched as a kid and you
get to meet up with these characters and
interact with them and honestly some of
the previous Kingdom Hearts games have
had worlds like the Welcome Mulan you
have Halloween town from Nightmare
Before Christmas
but in Kingdom Hearts 3 they're adding a
load of brand new ones they're really
taking advantage of Disney's
relationship with Pixar so you get to
explore Toy Story world and you know
meet up with Woody and Buzz but honestly
the whole thing about Kingdom Hearts is
it's such a beloved franchise and fans
have been waiting so long for Kingdom
Hearts 3 that everyone is incredibly
excited that 2018 is finally gonna be
the year now you might know the God of
War games as being steeped in Greek
mythology but God of War the new one at
least is kind of a soft reboot of the
franchise and instead it's taking the
lead character Kratos away from Greek
mythology at the end of God of War 3 you
know who kind of wreck things up a
little bit at Mount Olympus for Zeus in
the rest of the gods and it's taken him
into Norse mythology so it's a
completely new setting it's on the
PlayStation 4 it looks incredible and
it's a whole new kind of world
to explore monsters to battle but not
only that you're not just playing with
Kratos anymore Kratos has a son and it's
kind of like this father-son adventure
relationship-building you know you're
kind of teaching your son how to survive
in this harsh cruel world
and you're kind of helping him grow up
but what's very exciting about god of
war is that it kind of been built from
the ground up on PlayStation 4 and
everyone's really excited to see where
this new era
so that's it for our first week back
join me again for more swipe next week
and in the meantime follow us on twitter
at sky news white bye bye